okay let's get to the phones at 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 and see what is on people's
minds today why don't we start with our
caller from the 6 7 8 area code who's
calling today from 6 7 8
hi David this is Joseph hey Joseph
what's going on hey crazy that I'm on
the show right now this is cool yeah my
question is about the 287g program do
you know anything about that I know
nothing about it what is it ok well it's
a basically a program about partnering
between ice and local sheriff's and I
was just well since you don't know
anything about it this is something I
wanted to ask you oh is this so maybe I
know and maybe I know about it but not
by that name is this the idea that ice
wants local sheriff's to be reporting to
them on immigration status of people
that they're interacting with
yes exactly ok what happens with program
is basically deputized is the Sheriff's
Department to be ice officials and act
as ice officials and they get extra
funding because of so I was just
wondering about like is there any way
that state legislature could like fight
against that in any way with any kind of
legislation I don't know since it's
federal funding like yeah I don't know
the legality of it because so sheriff's
are usually County based and it's
unclear to me whether those are
decisions that the state could could a
state outlaw any County making the
decision to accept those funds what
happens in terms of the federal
supremacy I I genuinely have no idea
what the legality of it is I know that
I'm against it but I wouldn't be able to
say what the legality of a ban at the
state level on accepting those funds and
partnering in that way would be yeah
that was just my question because I live
in Gwinnett County and we actually
support 20% of the immigrants in this
small area so that's just a big issue
that's thinking about maybe like do a
video about it or something that'd be
super awesome just I honestly don't know
I've been researching in myself
I volunteer at the local Gwinnett
Democratic Party so it's just something
that I wanted to talk to you about yeah
well you know the thing is Joseph even
if there are funds available it's still
time that your local Sheriff's
Department is spending on something that
to you might just not be a valuable use
of time and that is a huge area where
people should be activating around I
mean if you live in a place and you
presumably have you do have an interest
in how the Sheriff's Department is
spending their time you should have a
voice which says I don't want sheriff's
wasting time communicating with ice
about the immigration status of people I
want them focused on whatever it might
be if there's opioid abuse issues going
on where you live or whatever else the
case may be this year so I think that
you should be activating around it and
you're doing the right thing by thinking
about this stuff yeah that's really
great yeah that's what I'm trying to do
I actually was speaking to a recent
candidate that's on the Democratic side
for hard Wynette's Sheriff and he was
talking about ending 287g program yeah
and I just was trying to think if
there's any other way if I could just
try and engage with my state reps or
things like that I would do it now
listen even though I don't know what the
legal circumstances are contact them
anyway and they can tell you what it is
make make them work and tell you what it
is all right Joseph thank you for the
call I really appreciate it important
topic and glad glad that you brought it
up to me hope to hear from you again